[Applause]
good afternoon and welcome to Colombia's
world leaders forum I'm John cotesworth
Provost of the University and I'm
honored to welcome Andre Frank Kovach
Prime Minister of the Republic of
Croatia for a talk on a very timely
topic the future of Europe a Croatian
perspective I would also like to
acknowledge the presence with us today
of mr. Pierre Simon ovitch ambassador of
the Republic of Croatia to the United
States as well as the other members of
the president's delegation I would also
like to thank Columbia's global policy
initiative for co-sponsoring this event
and acknowledge the presence of its
director University professor Michael
Doyle Croatia is at a pivotal point in
its development in 2013 it achieved the
long sought-after goal the nation became
the newest member of the European Union
Minister Prime Minister playing Kovich
career has placed him at the very center
of this transition and makes him
uniquely able to explain the meaning of
these events his background is a student
activist dating back to Croatia's
declaration of independence from
Yugoslavia in 1991 along with his
subsequent experience as a diplomat and
policy maker give him the necessary
background and experience in knowledge
to help as he did negotiate Croatia's
accession to the European Union bring
those negotiations to a conclusion as
Croatia's state secretary for European
integration
and then campaigned to generate public
support within Croatia for membership in
the unity union by explaining the
process of accession and the value of
becoming part of the Union
mr. Plinko it served as a member of the
Croatian Parliament and is one of the
nation's representatives to the European
Union and then last year was chosen by
the governing coalition to head Croatia
as its prime minister for the first time
since the global recession Croatia is
experiencing sustained if modest
economic growth and yet economic
instability continues to cast a shadow
over the nation and the region
a notable economic bright spot is the
record-breaking number of tourists
travelling to Croatia's Adriatic
coastline many of them attracted by the
fact that due ramnik is the main
location for the filming for the
location of King's Landing the capital
city of the game game of Thrones the
issues confronting Prime Minister
playing Kovich in Croatia are familiar
to us and serve as a reminder that
differences in geography and national
history sometimes prove secondary to the
power of global trends this past summers
headlines in Croatia spoke of battles
over immigration and the status of
refugees the rise of ultra nationalism
and intensifying debate about tax reform
and natural disasters including
catastrophic flooding and dozens of
wildfires Kurush is lucky to have as its
prime minister a man who is experienced
and capable of responding to all of
these crises at the same time we will
now hear from the Prime Minister about
not navigating these challenges and
learned from his expert perspective on
Europe a topic of great interest for all
of us here today please join me in
welcoming his Excellency Andrea Petkovic
prime minister of the republic of
croatia
[Applause]
good afternoon everybody and thanks a
lot director for this really modern
pertinent introduction into my speech
and let me first of all extend my
apologies for being late 15 minutes but
we had several commitments as you can
imagine during the United Nations
General Assembly whether these are
bilateral meetings or special events but
the traffic certainly has been not an
ally so to say in last few days I would
like to speak to you and here at the
Columbia University at this forum where
some of my predecessors have spoken as
well about Croatian perspective on the
future of the European Union you will
know that we have been a member only for
four years and three months and that we
joined the Union when some where some of
the scholars told us just before we're
drawing like you're as if you are
entering into a party very late at night
early ours when people are already a
little bit tipsy and leaving home this
was this was a comment by actually Niall
Ferguson when I spoke to him when he was
in Croatia a couple of years ago and a
few years later we're in and his own
country's actually on the way out so
this is a bit of a paradox as you could
see few months ago in Rome we all
celebrated the 60th anniversary of the
European Union it should have been
really a moment of new enthusiasm new
encouragement and reinvigorating the
spirit of the founding fathers who
signed the Rome treaty in 1957 this was
also a moment to try and embrace the
Roma gender and their own declaration
and remind ourselves selves of the
values that the Union is a
built and these values are indeed peace
democracy freedom rule of law market
economy I would say that even today with
all the difficulties that we observe
around the globe are similar to the
European Union just as they are for the
rest of the world indeed these internal
challenges and global challenges in the
altered world of communication where
everybody is communicating with everyone
instantly sometimes with arguments often
without arguments is creating a job for
those who run the European organisation
in the European Union more demanding
than it was ever before the European
Commission who has this role of being
not only a guardian of the treaties but
the initiator of further integration has
come up with several scenarios in their
paper several months ago and this paper
and its validity is still a topic that
is widely discussed in the number of
member states and in the various fora of
our new institutions you know the
scenarios whether we should carry on as
we used to so far whether the European
Union should go back to the single
Martic market and nothing else whether
we should adopt a scenario where those
who would like to do more actually do
more or should we do less in a more
efficient manner or should we do much
more together these five scenarios none
of them is exclusive and even in the
words of the Commission president who
had the State of the Union address last
week in Strasbourg at the plenary
session he actually proposed a six
scenario I've been saying all along that
we need to do a mixture of those
scenarios because the optics of member
states is not that much aligned
as it was let's say 20 25 years ago or
in 2004 when we had the biggest
enlargement of the group what we need is
a sense of realism and at those of
optimism for the project to succeed and
for the project to be as attractive as
it was before and also a model for
regional organizations across the globe
this power of attraction of the Union
serves as an instrument for
transformation of those who would like
to be the part of the club indeed from
my point of view and my country's point
of view the two-speed Europe is affect
it is certainly a reality Croatia is a
very clear example how it tries to
become ever closer in the narrow circle
of the European Union's integration we
have two steps which are ahead of us
which are two overarching processes and
reforms which will strengthen our
belonging to the European project one is
to join the Schengen area as you know an
area of free movement which has due to
the refugee and migration crisis gone
through a certain crisis itself because
it has been an unprecedented situation
that you to the changes in and war and
poverty and conflicts and migration
flows in Middle East and Africa that not
only border controls have been
reestablish among the Member States but
it actually physical barriers and wires
have been instated on some borders very
few people would have anticipated an
envisaged such a scenario in the
European project where the freedom of
movement was one of the not only main
liberties but one of the greatest
achievements of the project from that
point of view
besides Schengen
Croatia has another goal to attain and
that is to join the eurozone Europe is
not anymore an ala carte project when we
wanted to join there was not an option
or an opt-out when we signed the
accession treaty back in 2011 we agreed
to fulfill the criteria for Schengen and
we agreed to fulfill the criteria for
the euro zone in few weeks from today we
will be launching a campaign for the
euro zone accession it is an exercise we
are doing between the government and the
Croatian national bank the general
calendar in front of us is to manage to
become a part of the exchange rate
mechanism to some time in 2020 and then
few years after that to become a fully
fledged member of the euro zone
what among my main points for the
European Union process in the future
what are the three elements which I
would like to see strengthened or
improved first one is to strengthen the
Democratic legitimacy of our
institutions and the and their
efficiency this is I guess some part of
the failure that I would refer later on
to and that is a series of unsuccessful
referenda on various new issues in many
of the Member States of the EU second is
to ensure better results of the wrist
ribbit redistributed power of the EU's
budgets and the impact of our common
policies on a concrete daily life of
every European citizen we need to
somehow transform the abstract good into
a very concrete benefit of each and
every citizen of the European Union and
the third element is actually to
increase the influence of the European
Union on the global scene in the global
governance
including in the organizations such as
the World Organization where I have the
privilege to represent my country and
lead the delegation here at the United
Nations for many reasons and one of them
is the rise of populism across the
member states of the European Union we
somehow feel the increasing lack of lack
of confidence in the European Union
project
I became fully aware of this phenomena
in 2014 during the European Parliament's
elections I think it had two features
these European Parliament's elections
despite the fact that my own political
family which is the European People's
Party and I'm the president of the
Croatian Democratic Union as a member of
this family managed to win those
elections to have our representative as
a president of the Commission to have
our representative as a president of the
European Council to have our
representative now as the president of
the European Parliament and had all
three major institutions nonetheless the
2014 elections for the European
Parliament were really a signal of a new
phenomenon one in some countries
including mine
the participation was low below the
expectations and people still didn't
grasp why we should have a directly
elected any peace in a body of 751
somewhere in Strasbourg and somewhere in
Brussels second phenomena was that
relative winners in big countries some
of them the founding members were the
country where the parties with the
entire European agenda you saw it in the
United Kingdom it was you Kip you saw it
in France it was a national front you
saw it in Spain it was podemos or see
you the darkness even you saw it in
Italy it was cinque stella and the
guerrilla you could see it also in
Germany naina
not in a sense that they would be a
relative winner but for the first time
ever the alternative afield Island
managed to get seven seats in the
European Parliament not to mention the
result of Bravo and Pravda in Poland or
some of the parties who have a clearly
entire European agenda in the other
countries so in a way the European
elections did not only become a moment
where you have the opportunity to
express a protest vote against the
national government or the the moments
of national politics but also as a
platform where populist parties with
entire European agenda get introduced
into the EU institution then they use
them against the project at home this
was so plastically visible in the case
of a subsequent referendum in the United
Kingdom I always said when the first
time I read the speech of David Cameron
that he was going to call the end to a
British British debate on the membership
in the EU that it was an unnecessary
exercise that will not do any good to
anyone and we actually have a loss
situation for him loss situation on a
long run I believe also for his party
loss situation for the UK lose situation
for the EU and lost situation with when
we pull the line after everything
they'll draw the line after everything
loss situation globally because when a
permanent member of the Security Council
leaves the club in a country who has one
of the most strongest defense forces in
our club or this country who is the
champion of the free trade decides to
leave after the referendum which was won
predominantly by manipulation of anti
European forces who use their position
and the stage of the
in Parliament in a way that they
actually spoke about everything but very
little about the truth then we have a
problem then democracy as such has a
problem and it is a paradox that we will
have to live with but as the French say
the popular at home che or vox populi
vox Dei we have to find a solution a
similar example of a negative referendum
on Europe was a referendum organised in
2016 in the Netherlands the referendum
which was organized by a group of I
would say VIN provocateurs
who use every single European item - a
little bit distract the national policy
and what they picked up as an
interesting issue and use the citizen
initiative to organize a referendum by
electronically collecting four hundred
thousand signatures imagine on a
referendum on the conclusion of the
association agreement between Ukraine
and the EU you can of course imagine the
span of possibilities for Ukrainians to
influence the Dutch internal political
debate possibilities zero result just
enough - to have the referendum valid
32% which represents 0.61 percent of the
total population of the European Union
and the referendum clearly a no clear
now no we don't want to conclude an
association agreement video what were
the lessons learned of this one
very few political actors actually
committed to fight for the idea the
mainstream parties were a bit lukewarm
because they were all facing elections a
year later and none of them was really
properly involved so what we had is
a signal to a country who lost 10,000
people in last three years after rebels
in the country supported by Russia tried
to not only to destabilize the European
orientation but actually temporarily
occupied part of the territory of the
country and annex illegally Crimea so
you send a message to a country where
10,000 people have died with European
flags in Maidan we want to join the EU
and then few provocators in the nether
let's say oh no no no we don't want you
you don't you don't even qualify for a
waiting room you should be further away
morally and ethically extremely negative
experience and I have to admit when we
were discussing at the European Council
a special document which would have
addressed the concerns of the Dutch and
when I read it I said to two fellow
leaders in a very clear manner that this
was going to be a document that maybe
should not be that much publicized
because a lot of things that we have put
there as an accommodation to Dutch would
not be something that be extremely proud
of knowing that the realities of of the
country which aim to join so one of the
elements is the rising population which
we need to fight I'm doing it at home
constantly we need to do it by being
credible and by explaining what the
European project is and what the
European policies are and from from that
point of view the next European
elections will be a serious test for the
mainstream parties and this debate of
those who are for audio or against the
project will be seen visibly more than
ever
and we all have a strong task to engage
more forcefully in the campaign
in the debate when it comes to the
European policies here we will be now
embarking on to a discussion of a next
multi-annual financial framework
basically it's the EU budget that lasts
for seven years which is about one
percent of the total of GDP of the
European Union so only one percent and
it entails around 150 billion euros a
year for the diesel commitments of
payments this is actually a lot of money
even though if it's only one percent and
the way we spend it the way we invest in
our agriculture the way we invest in our
regional development the way we invest
in our science and technology the way we
support the prevention of youth
unemployment the way we invest into
science and the Digital Agenda it is
going to be a test whether we are
successful or not whether the European
budget really becomes as an added value
to be more equal and more faster
catching up of those countries who are
not as developed as those who were
privileged enough to be on the right
side of the island curtain and that's
where complete effect of our budget and
our policies especially for the
countries of our size are critical in a
sense that we explain that effect to the
living standard of our citizens is going
up because of the membership and not
that it becomes some sort of an elusive
category where nobody can really grasp
why we join the club another element
which is crucial from my point of view
is the global role of the European Union
this is indeed a right moment to say it
when the Secretary General of the United
Nations speaks about the reform of the
world organization whether it's
elephant or peacekeeping or trying to
address the megatrends in our globalized
world in a more efficient manner after
conflict or more useful and of course
more welcomed manner before the conflict
in terms of prevention the European
Union can do quite a lot it is becoming
also gradually but especially after we
have absorbed the Western Western
European Union it is becoming a
collective defence organization there is
no real properly copy/paste automatism
in terms of article 5 of the Washington
treaty but it is certainly a direction
where the project is going so from that
point of view the Union which has strong
foreign policy of member states should
be a bit more cohesive altogether
especially in the crisis situations
second it should use its level leverage
in the defence industry in a manner
where we are more compatible with each
other and where our spending up to the
two percent is not spent in a way where
we are only fulfilling the obligations
to have a basic or stationed forces but
forces which are interoperable quick to
react and complimentary with other
organizations a foreign policy which
would certainly draw on the large pool
of the development aid that the Union is
doing we are the largest donor in the
world
actually our Croatian Commissioner in
this composition of European Commission
is in charge of the development policy
we should use our trade arm which is
perhaps the strong is because that's how
the project started 60 years ago we
should use all other elements of our
policies which have the foreign element
and then in a comprehensive manner be a
partner which is recognized by all other
critical actors globally and
a partner that really makes the
difference and I feel having been also
vice-chair of the European Parliament's
Foreign Affairs Committee that we've
really gone a long way compared to where
we were let's say 20 25 years ago there
are quite a few people at least from the
Croatian delegation here who expected a
lot by the EU back when our country was
a victim of at the time aggression of
the Serbian and Serbian Milosevic regime
and when we expected the EU will somehow
with all this nice blue flags and 12
golden stars act immediately stop the
war help us and everything will be ok
but the tools were in there they simply
weren't in place a different issue
whether is there was a sufficient
political will but even if there would
have been a will the tools were not in
place now we have the tools we have the
lessons learned and I think we have more
space to be a credible international
actor where a contribution of the bigger
States medium-sized states and the
smaller states can be combined to an
extent that our foreign activities are
seen as a policy of a European Union
that primarily stands firmly behind the
values that it has instruments and the
budget to back up these values and these
policies this is how we become a
relevant partner on the global scene and
this is the line that my government is
taking within the internal debates of
the club and this is what we shall also
advocate when we represent our country
in the wider for such as the UN General
Assembly I very much agree with
president Juncker who said Europe was
not - made standstill it should move on
the Lord one of his famous predecessor
says
like a bicycle if we stop running the
the bicycle and we might fall so despite
all the attempts to destabilize the
project regretting the brexit we still
will find enough force to have this
project which I think was a peaceful
continental projects for last 70 years
as strong as attractive for even
Croatian neighbors in the years to come
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Laughter]
thank you for your thought provoking
comments mr. prime minister and now I
open the floor for discussion we are
having Mike in the middle and please
form a line behind it please bring it
back right and while the line of
interested to ask a question is being
formed let me break the ice with the
first question you ended your
presentation by saying that Europe was
not made to stand still but it was also
not made to shrink but to enlarge and
for the first time in history we have a
shrinking EU so what do you think what
are the chances for EU enlargement after
brexit and Croatia was particularly
pushing for further enlargement of the
EU to cover countries of the South East
Europe can you tell us something more
about it first of all even thank you
probably not very few very very many
people in the audience know that I used
to be the chef de cabinet when I was 25
when a man was a deputy foreign minister
in Croatia so we have a long history
together and I'm very happy he has been
one of our highest position diplomats in
the system of the United Nations and
Rudolph who is a British liberal who was
an MEP very experienced and very
prolific in terms of writing said that
for many years the European Union was
devising a parking
position which would be something close
to membership but never proper
membership for turkey and told me
privately that somehow I fear if the
referendum is organized that this
parking lot may end up being a lot for
my own country so he anticipated the
shrinking several years ago to be very
open there are very few countries now
who are strongly and openly advocating
Swift enlargement the mood is simply not
there somehow the digestion of the
enlargements of 2004 which was the ten
then 2007 Bulgaria and Romania and
eventually Croatia 2013 is still a very
much of a process the economic crisis
the perennial institutional debate
deepening widening the I would say
crisis of the Schengen zone assert a
certain point crisis of the eurozone
rise of the populism rise of the extreme
parties has shared a bit of a fear in
the mainstream of the political parties
of the key member states who always
drive the processes whether we have it
medium or smaller size like it or not to
be the strong advocates of the
enlargement we are the on the other hand
since we are the late comer to the club
understand the importance of the process
and saying openly to countries who wish
to join no way you will enter during my
watch which is five years mandate of the
Commission or the Parliament is in my
view more dissuasive than encouraging so
I think we should as quality be a little
bit more careful in calibrating in the
language there are some countries and
the closest one of course is Montenegro
which is Croatia's member neighbor they
are doing fine Serbia is making a lot of
efforts some other countries of the
region are doing a lot of efforts but I
still believe that
any fifth enlargement is simply not in
sight it will be a carefully guided
process Beit based on all sorts of
lessons learned of the previous
enlargements but predominantly the
current mode in the public's and the key
political parties will be you I thank
you very much I would be tempted to ask
you more questions including about
Ukraine on which you know a lot but we
have a queue formed here and I don't
want to keep you waiting so can we start
with the first group of questions before
asking a question would you kindly
introduce yourself mention institution
you are affiliated with so let us stop
good afternoon mr. prime minister thank
you for being here my name is michael
Rovner I'm at this an undergraduate at
the school of general studies here at
Columbia and I wanted to ask you I have
heard from some Europeans who believe
that European Union policy is primarily
driven by a few countries for their
benefit and said these set countries
have special privileges within the
European Union that don't extend to all
the countries so I was wondering if this
is true what can be done to change this
and if this is not true what can be done
to combat this false perspective thank
you I thank you very much let's take a
couple of questions and give a chance to
Prime Minister please
and knowing that unfortunately we do not
have much time be kind and ask just one
question and be focused and to the point
my question is that you seem to be a
huge advocate of the integrated policy
of the European Union so do you believe
a very uniform or standard policy will
help your country because your country's
situation is different from many others
like Germany France which are highly
developed
so my question is like this all your
believe a flexible approach will be
better thank you
I thank you Thank You Prime Minister
feel very eloquent speech my name is
edgar Eliot UN's a sophomore at Columbia
College my question concerns Columbia's
Croatia's entry to Schengen and
considering the EU usually demands that
a nation soules any territory disputes
that it may be involved in before being
admitted to the body and yet there is an
ongoing international territorial
dispute between Slovenia and Croatia
does this necessarily prevent Croatian
entry to Schengen and if not what sort
of message does this send to other
countries attempting to join Schengen
with respect to the credibility of the
body itself and the practical question
of the exact demarcation of the border
thank you thank you very much let's take
one last question and then give the
floor to Prime Minister yes Thank You
mr. prime minister again I am Robert
Bullard I am a sophomore and Columbia
College I had the chance this summer to
pass some time in the Balkans
unfortunate was in Croatia I'm studying
a migration of migration and the refugee
crisis and I'm interested you know there
were Croatia is on the route on the way
through Southeast Europe to countries
like Germany and there were some
concerns over closed borders open
borders and what initiatives Croatia
should take to accepting refugees and
migrants and I'd be interested to hear
what perspectives you have on that I
thank you very much
back to Prime Minister thank you even
thank you for all the four questions
which you have put the first one whether
the EU serves only few countries or it
serves the whole club well I
deliberately when I came to the European
Parliament wanted to join the Budget
Committee when you join the Budget
Committee then you look at the numbers
when you look at the numbers then you
can only properly see what are the real
priorities of the organization company
civil society organization or even
university and these numbers are
revealing because out of 28 countries 10
countries contribute to the 80% of the
budget 80% of the budget those who
contribute a lot of course are those who
are economically most developed or
biggest by size and through a very
developed system do finance the majority
of the operations thus their influence
also in terms of votes in the council is
pondered by their leverage in a way but
nevertheless the smaller countries get
their portion of the budget but what we
all share are the same policies and
these policies are key Europe is a
project made by law it creates certainty
it creates predictability
it creates reliability and it gives you
an international legitimacy and that's
why even if you are a bigger medium size
are small you can profit from the
project the idea is that your
institution's the people who work on the
EU dos seus or whether it's the funding
whether is the implementation of the
ickey whether it's part of our external
policies simply do it in the most
efficient manner those who are more
efficient get more profit I would say
that's the only rule I wouldn't say
there are those who are privileged and
that the project was only intended for
the few of the 28 the other question was
a question about the flexibility whether
we are all in the same position or not
of course we are not Croatia is doing
well in
of economic growth continues growth of
the GDP low unemployment rate the most
successful tourist season that we have
had since 1990 we witness now but in
terms of economics training in terms of
our industry in terms of our exports in
many other macroeconomic indicators we
can't be really compared with the
countries who are far more developed and
who have been in the club for a long
time or who have been democracies for a
long time this is a difference the idea
is that the EU policies help us to
shorten the time frame so as to catch up
with those who are better developed and
that's how my country sees the EU
policies and the EU budget and
everything that we are doing on Schengen
and Slovenia here I think it's important
for you to understand that the Schengen
does not have any legal preconditions
that being a part of Schengen requires
solution of a border dispute I always
say that the European Union law or the
ickey is not a substitute to the
international law borders are very much
competence of Member States it would be
excellent if all borders would be solved
but I have never witnessed that the work
of a Belgian Dutch Commission on the
demarcation of their border which is now
being active for about hundred years has
reached the table of the College of the
commissioners the table of me at the
European Council or even any Committee
of the European Parliament the point is
that we should simply distinguish which
are the dossiers that do have a
substantial connection with yaki and
which are those that are nonetheless
even though we if we are all in the club
left for the Member States to solve so
Croatian Slovenian border issue is one
of those residual elements of the
dissolution of the former Yugoslavia our
general line for last 25 6 years is the
the borders should be established as it
was on the 25th of June 1991 on the day
that Croatia's Parliament declared our
independence the Slovenian did the same
and the work of the two countries is to
work basically on details we went into
in 2009 after the Slovenia has blocked
14 chapters in the process of the
accession negotiations which in my view
were entirely unrelated with the ickey
because of the open border issues in
good faith into something which was a
basically an ad-hoc arbitration where
Slovenia and Croatia allocated one judge
each and the three other judges with the
help of the European Commission were
from France from the UK and from Germany
so despite the fact that we went into
this process in good faith the process
was compromised due to the call I would
say corrupt behavior between the
Slovenian agent and the Slovenian judge
thus revealing the data that should have
never been made known to one of the
parties and our parliament unanimously
decided back in summer of 2015 to
withdraw from the arbitration and then
we duly notified everyone as a lawyer I
would have thought that the arbiters if
they are deciding on a case where one
party decides to leave should have said
immediately well what are we going to do
how can we continue process where one of
the parties is not participating but
they actually did continue and this was
something which I would call now more as
a lawyer extremely unusual as a
politician I would call it unacceptable
so they delivered an arbitration award
in late June this year which established
by and large that the cadastre line the
line that Croatia was advocating all
along in terms of the land borders
should be accepted with some smaller
exception and then on the sea the
limitation they followed another
bilateral attempt of 2011 when it comes
to one area of Croatian and Slovenian
coast called this avoid risk of a
appearan Bay pending within Slovenian or
a crowd and then of course the line
which goes out to touch the Italian
Italian territorial sea now the position
of my government is to embark on
bilateral negotiations with Slovenia
trying to address this issue and solve
it Slovenia on the other side on the
other hand would like to implement the
award so it will acquire a lot of
maturity a lot of skill both political
courage and diplomatic skill to find a
solution that would put behind us an
issue that has by and large unduly
burdened otherwise very good
relationship that we have between
Croatia and Slovenia and on Schengen
will continue preparing technically
politically we will join and we will not
accept any situations where our
membership would be pending on solving
problems which are unrelated with
Schengen on migration you're right
Croatia was only eastern Mediterranean
West Balkans route especially in
2015-2016 the estimate says that around
700,000 people passed through Croatia
because predominantly their destination
was either Germany or some other
countries of Western Europe where the
rights given to the asylum seekers
refugees or migrants were in economic or
social terms far more comforting than
the ones in our country but you
mentioned the issue of solidarity and we
as
a member state who understands that
there should be a burden sharing among
the EU member states are willing to
accept and basically have as a host
those migrants or refugees which would
be within the quota that Croatia due to
its size and its economic strength is
supposed to receive so an issue of
solidarity was never questioned in
Croatia and especially not in my
government and may underline that unlike
some other states we never opted for a
barbed wire on our borders I thank you
very much we do not have time for
another full round of questions only if
questions can be telegraphic and if you
want to expose yourself to such a
challenge that answers are very short ok
please be quick we need to depart in 10
minutes so let's start please 15 minutes
yeah please tango saying that I'm here
my name is Karl Karl Ulrich I'm in
Colombia college freshman in your
remarks you talked extensively about
European integration and notably the
benefits of that integration experienced
by ordinary citizens to that end I want
to know what challenges reforms
domestically do you see is most pressing
and how does your government intend to
proceed thank you thank you you were
really quick followed the good example
the provecho
Prime Minister thank you for coming to
our campus this evening my name is Dinko
francese undergraduate here studying
mathematics and my question this evening
is regarding the large number of
educated and skilled Croatians leaving
the homeland and what is your government
aiming to do both for the short term and
for the long term to address this and do
you think that this is unavoidable with
Croatia being in the you thank you thank
you
Lavetta my name is tina reg coach I'm a
graduate student from Croatia
at the School of Applied Sciences and I
was hoping to hear your thoughts under
all of the United States and your future
of the European Union especially in
light of the ever closer Union which you
were discussing and in light of the
skepticism that has surfaced with the
new administration in the US thank you
thank you hello mr. president
my name is Dominic Cara Marco I'm from
the SPS of Colombia and I'm a visiting
undergraduate from Germany and I have a
question regarding the introduction of
the euro currency you just mentioned in
your speech it is required that you
lower your national debt to 60% as of
nowadays like 84% of your GDP and I
would like to ask how you try to
convince the Croatian citizens to accept
that introduction
considering the measures necessary to
lower national debt thank you
last question hello mr. prime minister
my name is ricardo Taveras under student
at the School of Professional Studies as
well I've heard from some creations that
there has been some efforts to black of
blackmailing from Slovenia and hungry
and I was wondering what's your opinion
on it is it true and if it is what what
has been your government's response to
it I thank you very much
back to you Prime Minister okay well
there was a question on on the domestic
reforms that would require another
occasion with an entirely different
subject as an introduction but if I may
say that the ambition of my government
is really to after really a while embark
on serious structural reforms that
Croatian society and Croatian
institutions require
that would not only touch the reform of
the state administration the reform of
judiciary the reform of our health
system our pension system the reform of
our educational system it would require
the full implementation of the document
which we call the national program of
reforms which is an annual document that
we adopt normally in spring and then
through a concept called European
semester and the annual growth survey we
are carefully monitored and watched by
the Commission whether we are attaining
these objectives this is a task of each
and every Minister this is a ambition
that we all share and this is what we
have been elected for to undertake those
reforms from the period of 2016 until
2020 when Croatia will actually have for
the first time the opportunity to chair
and be the president of the Council of
the European Union when it came to the
question on the United States role in
the European Union's policies we have
seen an even every month we see an
evolutionary process in terms of general
approach to the International Relations
and foreign policy and multilateralism
by the administration of President Trump
I said yesterday for the Croatian media
that for me his speech was something
that I was expecting where he still
maintained the America first and even
encouraged all of us to say Croatia
first Oh Slovenia first of Hungary first
he opened his wreath oryx and his
actions more to the international
organizations and to the international
cooperation this I think was a very
important message yesterday we will
continue the dialogue we have there
we have a transatlantic partnership
there was a big ambition to sign the
TTIP a treaty that would have created
far more jobs on both sides of the
Atlantic and enabled us to trade much
more than it was before this is
something that will be a task for many
of the European commissioners and many
of the European leaders whether speaking
as one over the speaking bilaterally
bilaterally with the American
administration on the euro currency I'm
very happy you are carefully observing
the Maastricht criteria there are five
of them but we are lowering the public
that very steadily and there is a clear
timeframe how we intend to go down to 60
but you have to know that the criteria
are a little bit more sophisticated just
reaching the 60 the idea is the trend
and the trend is really clearly
recognized by the European Commission
that is following what we are doing that
we are going in the direction the
Croatian public knows that when we
signed the accession treaty back in 2011
we already committed to become part of
the eurozone so it is not an issue that
would require another I would say a
referendum consultation of the Croatian
population because when they voted on
the 22nd of January 2012
by a clear vote 66 to 33% which is a 2:1
ratio they actually voted at that moment
also that Croatia joins the eurozone the
last question was more of a question
linking what the crowd students are
saying to other students if there is a
black male about the OECD membership
bye-bye to neighboring countries OCD is
the only intern
organizations where we could technically
actually become a member it's highly
unlikely we'll ever be g7 or g20 or
something like that we lack a bit of a
Gabourey for that type of leak but the
OECD is an organization which would give
us I would say a final stamp that we
have done everything possible in terms
of transition transformation functioning
of our institutions credibility of our
legal system and a leverage that we are
part of a group of states across the
globe who have attained standards that
those who are not in the club haven't in
2007 deu adopted the common position
saying that those member states who are
part of the club
meaning the OECD should support those
who are members of the EU but not yet
members of the OECD so instead of a
blackmail I would say that we what we
have witnessed is a violation of the
common position of the 2007 each country
from its own perspective one trying to
link the implementation of the
arbitration award which for Croatia does
not exist but of course we are saying we
will discuss the open bilateral issue on
borders and Hungary more linked with an
issue that has to do from their optics
protection of their investments in the
Croatian oil company called ena which
was privatized and bought by Hungarian
oil company Mall or two on two occasions
but there is a dispute there was a one
arbitration in the UNCITRAL and the
other one still active in Washington in
front of exit and a series of other
issues of corruption or former Croatian
Prime Minister for Massey of Mall so an
extremely complex issue where our
position is that those
legal elements should not be mixed with
a political ambition of Croatia to
become a member of the OECD and we have
said it clearly I said it in the
Parliament we have conveyed this message
to the Hungarian side we have convey
this message to the Slovenian side we've
learned a lesson that the blackmail link
is simply a no-go it will not pass it
will not fly as a member of the European
Union I can play the same game whenever
I would like to do that but those are
the moves which you don't do to
countries that have been with you
standing by for centuries and will
remain there so I would opt for a smart
diplomacy in politics rather than the
blackmail thank you in concluding let me
thank Prime Minister for being a guest
of Columbia University and global policy
initiative I would also like to say and
that you have clearly reflected that
European dream is not only good for
Europe but it's good for the world as
well so good luck to the EU good luck to
Croatia good luck to you personally in
pursuing this dream you were late but
you stayed longer and answered all
questions so you do deserve I forgot
what about
thank you very much even not to be
adapter to one of the students I see
there are many Croatian students who
actually raised one of the critical
issues and that is the issues of many of
the Croats leaving Croatia in last
couple of years this is unfortunately a
trend which is characteristic for many
of the countries of Central Eastern
Europe countries of greater size have
far greater waves of their citizens
going to some other member states if you
look at the number of Polish citizens in
living in UK now you would be really
stunned by the numbers I remember when I
was working in Paris back in 2005 there
was a referendum at a time on the
constitutional treaty and that's where
the referenda started to go wrong one in
France and one in Netherlands and we
never ever recovered on a national level
on the U issue so everybody now is
trying to avoid any referendum if
possible on the EU but there was the
story of the the friend of the Polish
plumber that all the plumbers in France
would lose their jobs because there
would be a plum be a pollen a flying in
large numbers with every charter flight
from what all Slovak rock of Warsaw
grinds it is true quite a few Croatians
in last couple of years not only in this
year have tried to see if they can find
a better job a better living in the
countries of Western Europe it is not a
trend that we are happy about it is a
task an extra task for us to create
conditions where our young and our
families and young families could find
their job in Croatia have a sustainable
income so as to rent or eventually built
or buy a house have a proper job form a
family and
this is also linked to a negative
demographic trend that we have we are
unfortunately one of those nations who
are literally losing people every day
and this is one of the most serious
tasks that my government has it is very
difficult to be a prophet whether we can
stop this by some sort of miraculous
policies but with all the policies that
I have mentioned in terms of structural
reforms and other efforts that the
government is doing if we create enough
preconditions for our young to remain
then the number of those who are opting
to go abroad would diminish at the same
time you know when we were selling the
referendum of our membership to the you
to our public we said this is good
because you will have a chance of
ability you would be able to spend a
part of your working life or a studying
period just as many of you are now here
in the u.s. studying somewhere else
acquiring an external knowledge coming
back and bringing this and investing
this into Croatian society Croatian
economy so it is a two-way process it is
very difficult to defend this this trend
when when you see it visibly and we see
it very much in the area of Slavonia
it's in an area that was very much
affected by war very much an
agricultural part but still the policies
of my government are oriented to invest
into that part of Croatia so as to
prevent greater flow of migration of our
young and unemployed sometimes so I see
that you are having good time with
students of Columbia University but I
also see that your entourage wants to
spare you a diplomatic incident if you
are late for another event so again
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]